we are asking you the people of this
city should we invest extra in this new
city block
currently we actually don't have any
projects that will be delayed everything
that was planned in the RTP is sure to
continue if it doesn't it would be due
to other vectors rather than this
particular project well I think it's a
new innovation to have a more it'll
revitalize air in a city area which has
been downgraded over a period of time a
lot of their core retail outlets have
moved away from their City area and I
think that will bring them me yes it's
called a procurement policy which means
that there will actually be a weighting
towards local businesses and that works
pretty successfully with lots of big
projects interestingly enough most
people would think that it is councils
responsibility for demolition to
commence however it is the
responsibility of the developer and the
developer had made that decision to
commence demolition so to meet the
requirements of contracts
it's a timeline thing and we can't
decide to halt the project and just
continue and not meet some of those
really crucial timelines just because
there's a possibility we might keep the
government funding if we were to do that
some of those contractual obligations
could have fallen off well that's an
interesting one actually interest costs
have gone down so that effectively means
they won't need to be any rates and
crystal update for what we are now
consulting on I think they've been very
honest to developers and they take have
taken a long-term view of how how this
will work
you just don't know that's the real
answer we didn't go to this project to
create jobs that's that's a side benefit
I guess that's we went there because we
felt that it was not a very good
financial investment and council has
acknowledged that there is a huge amount
of social good in reinvesting in a city
block I see this project being a
milestone and rejuvenation of our city
it's something that will give our city
hope and I would like to think it would
be the start of a domino effect yet to
come to rebuild and the Carroll
you